la côte varoise et ses nombreuses
criques
un paradis pour les pêcheurs du coin
[Musique]
nous sommes avec Alain 62 ans il pêche
depuis l'âge de 5 ans et connaît les
environs de hier comme sa poche
[Musique]
là on se dirige dans l'est de
Porquerolles
sur les Mèdes
il y a une crique c'est large rocheuse
où on va faire cette pêche aux petits
spas idée aujourd'hui pour la première
fois alain a accepté de nous donner
quelques-uns de ses secrets de pêcheurs
direction Porquerolles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'île de Porquerolles et taille une
vingtaine de minutes de la côte en
bateau alain est un peu ici chez lui
c'est son jardin secret et il connaît
tous les spots de pêche
extraordinaire je vais bien deux fois
par semaine lorsque le temps le permet
bien entendu au moins deux fois par
semaine
l'été c'est la période où je pêche le
moins parce qu'il y a trop de monde le
poisson était effrayé
donc là tu vas pas faire des grosses
pièces tu vas faire on va faire des
pièces
ce qu'on appelle des petits poissons il
y en a qui trouve ça gros déjà mais
c'est surtout parce qu'il est très
sportif comme poisson et je le prends si
tu veux comme si on tire au pistolet tu
vas voir on prend de très près avec une
canne très souple et c'est extrêmement
amusant c'est très sportif c'est très
c'est très amusant voilà parce que la la
blague autant que le ça a une défense
extrêmement vigoureuse et c'est un
poisson intéressant à pêcher pour ça
pour ce premier arrêt Alain vise la
pêche à l'aube ce petit Spar idée très
fréquent en Méditerranée mais très vif
de penser que les poissons
c'est fondamental le pécheur qui pense
que le poisson sont des idiots n'ont pas
d'intelligence les attrapera toujours
que par hasard que le poisson était
éduqué désormais le poisson est éduqué
c'est-à-dire que quand tu prends une
prise de prise
et redoute les cannes à pêche il les
voit ils sont pas idiots on est en sûr
qu'ils ont une intelligence
il faut réfléchir pour les propres voilà
donc j'ai trouvé secret les pas les
prendre pour des idiots ah ça c'est
basique ensuite dans notre secret
d'aujourd'hui
je vais développer là en même temps que
je sorte du matériel là pour le
développement de matériel à prendre
pour cette petite entrée en matière elle
a choisi une canne bien spéciale
[Applaudissements]
alors là qu'est-ce que tu c'est quoi
ça c'est une canne ce qu'on appelle du
ultra light
qui a 10 livres de résistance donc il
constate elle est extrêmement
extrêmement souple avec un doigt la plus
ça ressemble un petit peu au petit
fleuret qu'on les pêcheurs de truites
avec un petit moulinet Daiwa Procaster
un fil extrêmement fin aussi je suis en
bas de ligne je suis en 20 centièmes 22
centièmes
parce que
plus le fil est fin et moi il est
visible
le poisson se défait
le lieu n'a pas été choisi par hasard ce
que Alain regarde avant toute chose
c'est son environnement
les gens que tu vois clairement que les
éboulis que tu vois au pied cette
falaise mais tu devines bien qu'il se
continue il y en a jusqu'à ici on va
dire jusqu'à
Alain va maintenant sortir son arme
magique une préparation dont seul lui
connaît la recette
ça c'est quoi
j'ai pas trop envie parce que il y a pas
grand monde qui le fait
je vais y aller
[Applaudissements]
ça ce sont des
de la nourriture pour
l'eau de rade dans ce serve les
pisciculteurs
que je bois finement très finement j'y
mets en plus quelques petites graines tu
vois que je ne sont pas moulues pourquoi
parce que celle-ci elles vont tomber sur
le fond s'éparpiller sur le fond et
faire progressivement un petit matelas
au fond là où les poissons du fond comme
les sars et tout sont les patrons
tu fais quoi là
on va faire une pâte
pourquoi
parce que tu vas voir donc faire une
pâte j'ai besoin d'avoir une pâte pour
l'accrocher au bout de
ça c'est pas c'est pas que pour un pâté
si tu as pêché avec c'est ça là
quand ils ont des boulettes au fond de
l'eau
il y en a une qui leur plaît et parfois
on a besoin
de manière dispersée comme là comme du
couscous on va dire
alors là ça va tomber sous la forme d'un
brouillard dans l'eau
ça sent très mauvais
ça sent très mauvais la caméra le tira
pas mais pour te dire que les mains il
faut les frotter longtemps après
maintenant je vais faire quelques boules
et elles vont descendre tu vois voilà
tout un art pour Alain qui a une routine
bien huilée et une méthode de pêche bien
à lui
il va maintenant mettre sa patte sur son
hameçon un trident et rien d'autre
alors tu as pas quoi tu as pas de
bouchon tu as pas de rien je suis en
direct
je la fais de forme pyramidale
pour qu'elle ait le moins de chance
possible
de sortir
de s'éclater on peut la faire de format
longé parce que les serres ont tendance
à venir
tu vois un truc comme ça qui commence à
avoir taper dedans
avec la tête il donne un coup il faut
surtout pas serrer parce que des fois on
entend que l'hameçon leur rique un peu
la sur la sur le front mais après ils
reviennent manger le reste alors on les
fait des fois un peu plus allongé
justement pour ça elle se casse en deux
et le morceau qui part il se jette
dessus puis il remonte chercher le
morceau initial et là il avale d'un coup
c'est là qu'on les faits
de quoi il parle il a bien pris son
temps pour préparer sa pêche mais une
fois prêt ça va très vite
[Applaudissements]
je pose pas beaucoup de
[Musique]
en très peu de temps c'est déjà la
première oblade
30 secondes à peine pour le premier
poisson et en effet l'aube se débat
vivement allez coriace un vrai combat
qui ravit à l'un
cette première au bled est une jolie
pièce de 15 cm mais l'espèce peut offrir
beaucoup mieux Alain c'est bien
[Applaudissements]
tout ça elle voit les hommes debout donc
ça c'est une taille moyenne tu peux
avoir plus grosse
sélection au niveau de la taille
et par contre on a des grosses et des
plus grosses j'ai lu sur des
magazines tu des revues que le plus
grosses sont 35 cm 36
c'est la taille de celle que j'ai pêché
les fois plus grosse 130 la plus grosse
36 cm c'est beaucoup 36 ça tire fort
alors au bout d'un moment comme ça des
dents tu vois le fil là
il commence à être user par les dents de
la
ici juste au dessus de l'hameçon le fil
on le voit il a déjà pris un peu et un
peu donc là il faut bien faire attention
si tu changes pas ton
tu refais pas ton nœud pour décaler
l'hameçon
tu
[Applaudissements]
un ton père elle casse et elle part avec
le truc
c'est pas bon pour ces petits poissons
[Applaudissements]
le pari d'Alain c'est le péché les
autres oblades maintenant méfiante en
moins de 30 secondes
le top chrono est pris et pour ne pas
tricher la caméra reste allumée
[Applaudissements]
principe étant de fatiguer le poisson
avec la canne regarde tu vois la canne
qui est très souple fatigue le poisson
le frein
pas que ce soit verrouillé
l'objectif de cette matinée c'est de
ramener une bonne demi-douzaine de
sparrides pour un dîner ce soir en
famille
est-ce que la technique d'Alain va
pouvoir le permettre car si les
premières oblades mordent rapidement
c'est pas gagné pour les suivantes
reste encore trois ou quatre Oblats
d'apprendre mais pour Alain les prises
vont s'espacer de plus en plus les
Oblates deviennent maintenant très
méfiantes jusqu'à ne plus se laisser
prendre du tout
donc Alain le bilan là
de taille
moyenne assez belle tout ça en combien
de temps
en temps de pêche réel n'est-ce pas
changement de spot et changement de
méthode de pêche
Alain nous réserve encore quelques
belles surprises et quelques beaux
secrets de pêcheurs
au loin il repère le chalutier de son
ami Cyril un t-shirt professionnel une
bonne occasion de lui demander quelques
crevettes fraîches elle n'a pas
redoutable ici aux abords de
Porquerolles
je vous avais pris pour Cyril
de loin j'ai mis le bateau bleu j'ai dit
c'est Cyril
alain est déçu mais il a plus d'un tour
dans son sac et il n'est pas du genre à
lâcher prise
alain a toujours avec lui des crevettes
congelées direction un haut fond de sa
connaissance qui l'a marqué sur son GPS
il est au milieu de la rade de hier un
spot pour les starsidés comme le pagre
le Pajot la dorade ou encore le Sahara
zone je vais
chercher la canne adéquate
je monte
la part va être accroché directement sur
le ténia mais pas n'importe comment
alors quand je pêche je laisse jamais
les la boîte comme ça je mets la
glacière là et à chaque fois j'ouvre la
glacière pour prendre une crevette pour
les laisser bien au frais mais là on va
pas pêcher des heures il fait pas très
chaud
le secret ici chez nous en Méditerranée
c'est la crevette vivante il y a des
roses
tu vois le rose
[Musique]
là-dedans
et on pêche ensuite avec ça alors voilà
comment ça c'est ce que la crevette
voilà d'accord
ensuite elle va être je vais te montrer
tout à l'heure
je la pique
la repique dans la tête tu vois bien
qu'il y avait une position très
naturelle
et le poisson il vient volonté de
prendre la tête parce que la première
chose qu'il attaque le poisson c'est la
tête
donc là elle a une bonne c'est important
elle est sur un hameçon qui est pas trop
fort de faire parce que tu vois c'est
quand même une toute petite bête les
crevettes roses sont petites mais c'est
une gourmandise
montrer comment
[Rires]
et c'est parti pour la pêche à la
crevette
si je dois avoir un secret moi ce qu'il
en est pas tout à fait un c'est
d'étudier des cartes avant d'aller à la
pêche toujours de devoir une étude
permanente non seulement des des fonds
mais aussi de leur des sédiments
péchés
tu l'as vu tu vois
donc il va pouvoir vivre en principe
c'est une animation pour
pour essayer de la tirer
pareil c'est le même combat la verrade
ou Sarah tête noire c'est un des
sparhider les plus féroces
et un poisson de plus pour le repas du
soir
mais Alain va interrompre brusquement sa
pêche
car au loin il a repéré un événement de
taille
là tout près des oiseaux
on peut
poser une présence des prédateurs en
dessous qui restent en effet au loin les
mouettes indiquent la présence d'une
chasse de Tony d Alain avant de se
rendre sur le site
installent un ordre bien particulier
l'astuce c'est de prendre des petits
c'est ça oui c'est de ressembler à un
petit anchois de début de saison tu vois
voilà
très fin
un halevin quoi quasiment d'accord
la pêche consiste à se rendre très
rapidement sur les lieux de chasse des
taux d'idées de couper le moteur et de
lancer en plein milieu du bouillon puis
de faire travailler son leurre au
moulinet
pour cette pêche improvisée je prends la
barre pour câlin puisse être prêt à
lancer à temps
attention à toi tout se joue sur la
vitesse d'exécution car en quelques
secondes les poissons se dispersent de
leur chasse
et en très peu de temps Alain faire son
premier poisson
c'est gros là
non
mais la pelamide est en fait bien plus
grosse qu'il n'y paraît peut-être une
ruche du poisson car quand il se
rapproche du bateau tout de suite ils
sont violemment au fond
[Musique]
et là c'est du sport
donc c'est une pyramide ça c'est quoi oh
oui
certitude alors c'est impossible mais
cette cette
obsession aller au fond comme ça
Alain doit jouer de patience il ne veut
pas casser et perdre son poisson le plus
beau de la journée
là c'est quoi la technique c'est la
fatigue
du fil en bas j'ai dû 30 centièmes plus
gros carbone c'est pas
non je peux je peux pas la prendre en
force si je verrouille un peu plus mon
moulinet je risque de casser
toutes les chances de casser là il faut
être patient
oh non elle est belle
[Musique]
tu sais il va falloir que je passe de
l'autre côté du bateau
non il y a la ligne de l'autre
j'ai vu le ruche tu as vu encore
tu la sors un peu plus ton tu sors un
peu plus ton salade un peu plus orienté
un peu plus horizontal
elle va rentrer dedans
voilà
ça y est
Alain ramène enfin saper l'ami d'abord
tu n'as présentes
donc là pour l'attraper il fallait voir
la chasse et avoir finalement le bonheur
c'est ça explique-moi oui il fallait
avoir le leurre de la taille et on est
en début de saison et les
[Musique]
les poissons qu'elle mange son petit
donc il faut les présenter des poissons
un leurre qui a la taille des poissons
qu'elle mange
au four 150
huile d'olive
c'est tout c'est tout simple
tout autour du bateau
alors je décide à mon tour d'essayer
Alain me prête sa canne et surtout me
donne ses conseils
[Applaudissements]
pour pour monter lentement lentement et
récupérer tu descends bouffe tu
récupères
du film
tu me l'amènes déjà
la journée a été très belle avec Alain
qui va se finir ce soir autour d'une
belle table dont seul à l'un le secret
[Musique]